[Music]
have you ever sat in a doctor's office
for hours despite having an appointment
at a specific time has a hotel turned
down your reservation because it's full
or have you been bumped off a flight
that you paid for these are all symptoms
of overbooking
a practice where businesses and
institutions sell or book more than
their full capacity while often
infuriating for the customer over
booking happens because it increases
profits while also letting businesses
optimize their resources they know that
not everyone will show up to their
appointments reservations and flights so
they make more available than they
actually have to offer airlines are the
classical example partially because it
happened so often about 50,000 people
get bumped off their flights each year
that figure comes at little surprise to
the airline's themselves which use
statistics to determine exactly how many
tickets to sell it's a delicate
operation sell too few and they're
wasting seats sell too many and they pay
penalties money free flights hotel stays
and annoyed customers so here's a
simplified version of how their
calculations work airlines have
collected years worth of information
about who does and doesn't show up for
certain flights they know for example
that on a particular route the
probability that each individual
customer will show up on time is 90% for
the sake of simplicity we'll assume that
every customer is travelling
individually rather than as families or
groups then if there are 180 seats on
the plane and they sell 180 tickets the
most likely result is that 162
passengers will board but of course you
could also end up with more passengers
or fewer the probability for each value
is given by what's called a binomial
distribution which peaks at the most
likely outcome now let's look at the
revenue the airline makes money from
each ticket buyer and loses money for
each person who gets bumped let's say a
ticket costs 250 dollars and isn't
strange Bowl for a later flight and the
cost of bumping a passenger is $800
these numbers are just for the sake of
example actual amounts vary considerably
so here if you don't sell any extra
tickets you make forty five thousand
dollars if you sell fifteen extras and
at least fifteen people are no-shows you
make forty eight thousand seven hundred
and fifty dollars that's the best case
in the worst case everyone shows up
fifteen unlucky passengers get bumped
and the revenue will only be thirty six
thousand seven hundred and fifty dollars
even less than if you only sold one
hundred and eighty tickets in the first
place but what matters isn't just how
good or bad a scenario is financially
but how likely it is to happen so how
likely is each scenario we can find out
by using the binomial distribution in
this example the probability of exactly
one hundred and ninety five passengers
boarding is almost zero percent the
probability of exactly one hundred and
eighty four passengers boarding is one
point one one percent and so on multiply
these probabilities by the revenue for
each case add them all up and subtract
the sum from the earnings by one hundred
and ninety five sold tickets and you get
the expected revenue for selling one
hundred and ninety five tickets by
repeating this calculation for various
numbers of extra tickets
the airline can find the one likely to
yield the highest revenue in this
example that's 198 tickets from which
the airline will probably make forty
eight thousand seven hundred and seventy
four dollars almost four thousand more
than without over booking and that's
just for one flight multiply that by a
million flights per airline per year and
over booking adds up fast of course the
actual calculation is much more
complicated airlines apply many factors
to create even more accurate models but
should they
some argue that over booking is
unethical you're charging two people for
the same resource of course if you're
100 percent sure someone won't show up
it's fine to sell there see
but what if you're only 95% sure 75% is
there a number that separates being
unethical from being practical
[Music]